Yass Panama's ale playing Beethoven's
sonata number 8 in c-minor known as the
petite eek and again as it might have
sounded in Beethoven's time
that's a flea actually composed the
beginning of the pathetic sonata in 1798
on a Valtor grand piano
the company is a historically authentic
performance requires a period instrument
or at least as in this case an accurate
reproduction this plate has that light
and a crisp sound when you play on this
you can hardly take note of what you're
hearing it's so undefined
sadly the ausf an M is eel founded the
anima Eterna ensemble in 1987 while
modern orchestras often increase the
number of instruments here the number of
musicians is the same as originally
specified by the composer the Koreans
we're trying to get as close as possible
to the composer and to play how we think
he wanted a good act at anima Etana is a
fluid formation with emma seal
reassembling his orchestra for each new
project only a fraction of classical
musicians worldwide master the art of
historically informed performance as
it's called and only a few of them have
period instruments
Yass pan Emma sale also runs a
masterclass for younger people with
three other instructors there's a strong
emphasis on public rehearsals the mentor
say having an audience adds to the
excitement although it's also supposed
to be fun it doesn't look strict but it
actually is Yass when Emma sail lives in
Bruges a medieval city where his
historical performances are highly
appreciated a permanent home for the
anime eterna ensemble proves that even
if the venue is the most modern affair
the concert Cubao completed in 2002
strictly speaking that wouldn't comply
with the principles of historically
informed performance but playing only in
authentic locations where the composer's
worked would mean having to have fifty
different concert halls it's simply not
possible the Belgian maestro has
collected a range of period keyboards
including both originals and
reproductions many of the replicas were
created with the help of professional
instrument makers and drawn from
historical sources which he likewise
collects
so we must as you wouldn't restore a
Rubens painting with latex you must not
play music by Beethoven on instruments
that he himself never heard from Indiana
malsky hurt
Yas Panama's ill and animate Anna giving
old music a new future